oh i'm working on a video right now and
like i've watched the clan ad dub and
there's just one scene where a female
teacher is just
voiced by a dude what really yeah
yeah like i'm i'm i'll it's i i
obviously can't show this but i'll show
you guys later and i'll
i mean this is why i didn't watch a dog
it's just like a scene i
watched it dub so i don't remember this
but i watched someone sent me the clip
and i'm like
that's just a dude hi boys
it's like what how did this pass
i mean there was a lot of weird things
that happened with dubbing back in the
day if we're going to talk about bad
dubs
yeah exactly you know we have to talk
about you know like ghost stories
ghost stories is that a bad job or is
that it's so bad that it's good
people people always act because when i
when i tweet out be like hey i'm going
to fix bad anime scenes for a youtube
video people always be like yeah fix
ghost stories i'm like what does it
affect there's nothing to fix
something's amazing it's [ __ ] great
it's just
because i from what i've heard about how
ghost stories came to be made
it was ghost stories just sold horribly
in japan so when they licensed it
licensed it over they were like yeah
do what you need to do to make this sell
yeah like dude
we you have there was so much creative
control yeah there were some was where
you basically you basically had full
creative control
and from what i heard like they were
just the voice actors would just
try to rush in the booth first and they
would just like ad-lib the scenes
and everyone else would have to like
play off what they said yeah it was like
the first
bridge yeah yeah yeah essentially i mean
yeah it's
it's weird to think right that dubs back
in the 70s
were done where there was no email
like how did they do this they were
literally a guy was given this
dvd and they just kind of made it i know
they just and the japanese
just hoped they did it well it's weird
right do you think there was even then
it was a trust system
yeah yeah yeah they're like i guess just
take this dvd
and go home yeah vhs
dvd what existed before dvd
so you just take this cassette laserdisc
yeah lazy
laziness never took off in the west but
it was japan oh my god yeah no it's
weird but even i think that's also why
some dubs now are a bit strange because
they were still done on that system
where if you go first you dub it and
then the person who comes next
has to dub but they get to hear just
your character who's been before you so
right yeah it was last normally the
easiest time
right yeah and that because they have to
kind of go along with oh they perform
this character in this way so i kind of
have to do it the same
but if the first one sucks it's a bit
unfortunate because i think it makes
this weird kind of feeling sometimes by
accident but this is again why a
director should be on top of that [ __ ]
yeah yeah
that's that's what that's why like the
director has control
over how this sounds because there are
definitely some dubs where it definitely
sounds like people
aren't having a conversation yeah yeah
i've always said i think a director's
job is like 10 to get the best
performance out of you and like
90 to make sure everyone sounds like
they're in the same world like that's
the hardest part
because you're constantly thinking like
okay that was a great line but does it
fit with what the other person just
delivered yeah like i need to think
about that yeah
it's a really hard skill it's it's
definitely hard because you have to be
on top of what
everyone is saying and how everyone
sounds and it's
it's definitely like you can definitely
see some of the nuances that
people don't normally think about but if
you if you play a conversation and it's
just like man these people just sound
like they're reading lines to each other
and not actually having a conversation
and it's really it just sounds yeah it's
that uncanny valley yeah
it sounds like they're kind of talking
through dimensions
one's living in one world and the other
was living in the other world and the
rift just happened to open up where it's
like oh hello
oh hi mark hi mark